sodas brought to you by mafia three
family is who you die for yeah we are
doing this what is happening screen
junkies central yes yes oh my gosh Andy
how can you believe this it is in full
effect this is day this is day 9 of
Comic Con feels like it oh yeah we've
been oh we've been uh talking all day
drinking all night and then repeat
that's it that's it and it's insane
costumes I love your costume sir what
are you yeah guy with a Hulk shirt get
me round of applause gotta love it Oh
Andy so we are about to talk to some of
the cast creators writers of one of the
great animated shows one of the funniest
shows in the history of television
Family Guy oh yeah yes indeed um I'm
pretty pumped about that I'm pretty
pumped I think they're here let's quit
talk and let's bring them out yeah
absolutely
oh who we got please welcome to the
stage Alex Borstein aka Lois Griffin Oh
wherever you like you are queen we are
your subjects Mike Henry cast writer
producer also you know him as the voice
of Cleveland
another member of the cast a writer
producer many voices on Family Guy Alex
Sulkin writer executive producer voice
actor Steve Callahan and producer rich
Appel you guys we are hashtag blessed to
have you here uh so one more Oh none our
list john fighters here come on actor
writer producer designer John sorry
about that someone's gonna get fired for
not having your seat they're just edits
probably me he's not wearing pants so
you guys a happy Comicon uh how many how
many Comic Cons have you guys
collectively done or do you do a Family
Guy
panel at Comic Con every year or talk to
us about your just your comic-con
experiences I don't remember
we get so completely shit-faced ha ha ha
it's just a blur I don't know like I
don't know tenable I am so blessed right
ha ha ha ha ha ha just kidding I don't
this is 10 or 11 we've done it we've
done it every year for like I think 11
years yeah we're old oedipal and an
apple yes ma'am um and how many so how
many seasons has Family Guy been on the
air now go on more Danish yeah 314 it
bets go on for like 15 years but we're
always like a year ahead
are you team that's perfect
how long do you think how would you want
to go like are you here are you trying
to compete with the Simpsons you think
you can out outlast them like it's
amazing and it'll be impressive what's
your what's your feelings on it well
we're more than halfway there so I think
it's gonna be pretty easy too many of us
bought houses that we're too expensive
so we're hoping that this continues yes
so you see like an end in sight or do
you two wanted us to a forever ever I
would love to do it forever so long as
the stories are fresh and funny and they
are like every table read I show up and
still like pee myself a little not from
childbirth because I had c-sections
but because the scripts are really
freakin funny yeah he out of the scar
now I pee out of the scar and my neck
and my nipples it's so weird
Wow okay and marry me and there's a
story
um I think peeing out of a c-section
scar would be a great joke on Family Guy
done uh and quagmire could do something
with a c-section scar right I don't know
um your minds are so will you go on
record saying that your goal is to crush
the Simpsons no we want to join them yes
in a what Amin what is Russia what what
is what is the key to that kind of
longevity cuz like that's it Sam that's
an amazing run what would you say you
owe that to Cale I'll say because I we
started in 9899 so Stewie now would be
what how old seventeen eighteen so
they're the characters don't age so we
can keep going forever
Barrie keep it fresh in the room like
because I imagine it is tough sometimes
like because I even Simpsons has made
the joke of we didn't you know they did
it we there's they've done the plots
again like how do you how do you keep
from making sure you don't you know
because you guys are so good at it but
like how do you is there a process to
making sure no we did that we can't do
that again
don't we just do it we're just go get
we've sometimes gotten halfway through
breaking a story and then someone says
wait a minute season six we did exactly
this it's usually this guy here
Steve Steve knows all of our story Steve
will give you the episodic number
and the act and the minute I have a rain
man like mine for that particular thing
for some reason it used to be early on
that we would be thinking up a story as
we go oh no the Simpsons did it or you
know and now we have to worry about that
and we have to worry about us having
done it too but we we used to worry
doing of the hill did it with that we
used to worry the king of the hill did
it remember king of the hill oh yeah oh
yeah yeah we got we had our first
executive producer david zuckerman wrote
for king of the hill so he would say
what no king of the hill dude hey Mike
do you know that rich ran king of the
hill did you run king of the hill I
don't want to make this all about me
Holy Smoke yeah you know Mike judge we
will Rican will steal some of those dirt
but you know you taught the world gives
us new stories I mean this coming season
we have a story where quagmire discovers
tinder for the first time and you know
and he kind of becomes this shut-in
Gollum who's swiping everything he can
possibly find and you know tinder didn't
exist years ago so we're just hoping
technology and we'll keep giving news
story and there's a big musical number
about how gross tinder yes and Cleveland
stings in the in the number with Peter
and Joe but we also have a very talented
staff of writers who you know we have to
give a lot of credit to those people who
are not here because we have a large
talented group of people who come up
with these stories and I think because
of the history of the show having been
cancelled and brought back literally by
the loyalty and and willingness of our
fans to spend money on DVDs and things
like that we take that responsibility
very seriously to keep the show fresh
and fun and exciting for the fans who
you know for many of us gave us our jobs
back wow that's amazing
um so you guys what one thing I love
about Family Guy it's that just the show
seems to be fearless and you really just
push the limits of comedy can you just
elaborate on any times where standards
and practices might have been like oh
that went a little too far or something
that maybe didn't make it to the air
because you guys it's wonderfully edgy
willing to follow up with and I remember
reading something from a Matt Stone and
Trey Parker like they'll always add
stuff that's even worse to distract them
like you do that trick too so we used I
feel like we used to think about doing
that but
you know there was the Weinstein episode
that didn't air originally and then
aired after we were brought back we had
a great long bit about pat tillman that
maybe people have heard about Pat
Tillman was a football player who
valiantly volunteered to fight in
Afghanistan and was killed by our own
troops and we had a very long bit about
that where Peter was like the sergeant
of Pat Tillman's platoon and just kept
giving people orders or he kept hearing
the orders and misinterpreting them of
like okay so well-well go and take that
bunker and then we shoot Pat Tillman and
there's no no we don't shoot Pat sonam
that's not what we do and I just kept
hearing the order that way it was a
really long funny bit that I think was
ultimately taken out but it was animated
and I believe like Pat Tillman's family
saw it and loved it which but that it
come how did they see it um it may have
appeared on as a DVD extra something
like that and I remember standards when
there was a an episode where they went
to the future and Meg was now
transgender and they wouldn't let us say
had a dictum II she hadn't a do you
remember the dirty sanchez one which I
love that that's my favorite story
because we tried to put in the reference
to dirty sanchez everyone know to dirty
sanchez is what is it out I'm gonna give
you a minute to Google and then later
Mike Mike and I will show you ub sanchez
what they would they wouldn't let us do
it and so he kind of like bent around it
and called it a muddy Ramirez oh love it
like brought us to a new piece of
language yeah that's worth of a vivid
picture and then there was a time when
we made up a word that was standing for
something really filth it was cleamen
right and they were they didn't want us
to do it and we said what doesn't mean
anything we've made you know and then it
ended up on the show and then as a
result ended up on urban dictionary so
then when we wanted to use it later they
said well no you can't because now it
has a definition of this really horrible
gross thing well we created that so we
can go around in all kinds of illogical
circles you've expanded the lexicon Wow
it's like spontaneous genetic mutation
on our show
that's that's amazing and when was there
what was the first time would you guys
ever like get in hot water for anything
like early on where it's like oh we
better watch our step or was it always
just lets push push push right yes
that's set the tone II just if it's
funny we're doing it there's no agenda
we have offend everyone which hopefully
means we have had no one yeah I mean
it's just we'd make any joke and that's
we've never played it safe
I'm just curious from the writing
standpoint like uh we have our Yzerman
do we do our honest trailers and we
always are trying to push like when does
the joke end or how I need go too long
like you guys have done some obviously
iconic moments the chicken fights edge
where you just you let the joke go-go-go
and sometimes it's that it's not funny
but then it's funny again like where is
the line and how do you guys have
arguments about that is do you all have
to agree on the length of those jokes I
don't know if we have arguments the
advantage of a show like ours as we get
after the table read and you record it
we watch a rough animated version of it
and and we react and we haven't seen it
for two or three months so you kind of
can tell and then three months later we
see it again in color so you screen
these things and you can tell if it does
exactly what you're saying you know
comes back to being funny or if we're
tired we just leave it as unfunny and go
it's very musical though I you know a
lot of people on the staff are musical
and comedies rhythm and music and to me
it just always feels like you have to
find the right the right rhythm and it's
very musical a lot of jokes are rhythm
you're they're not they're they're funny
for a second then they're not funny for
a while and then they start getting
funnier and funnier in front here in
front here it's kinda like sex - Joseph
is a climate um so is it always does how
often does and you shoot laughter at the
ceiling wow you're talented man thank
you so how often does van uh how often
does a joke like kill in the room or on
the page but then when it's animated
kind of just fall flat how tell me about
that process yeah I tell you about all
our unfunny
yeah sometimes it's what Borg could
attract our fans talk about our wings
because it's such a consistently funny
show but it's it's a weird visual medium
you could do anything as possible the
most painful contortions you and I'm
guilty of this too is after either a
table read with a cast or a screening
when there's a joke that you loved on
the page and it just died and you're
back in there and it's the only thing to
do is to cut it it clearly didn't work
but you don't want to because in your
head you remember the laugh and that it
wants God and you still like it and you
people are trying to negotiate in the
room and then say we were all in there
60 people did not look sometimes it's
the personality of the writer that
shines through and you say it so it's
hilarious
that's his personality but it doesn't
translate right to the grip or we tank
it at the table you know what you get
the script in you if you weren't in the
room when the joke was pitched you don't
know exactly how it was done and you
fail miserably delivering it at the
table and that sucks yeah when you read
it you've ruined the joke when you get
it the night before and you're reading
again this I would I would say this
differently as him I'd like to hear from
John Byner
John and Alec and I mean obviously Alex
14 in my Kendra are two great writers
for Family Guy and they're in the room a
lot and it's a huge advantage to have
Cleveland and Herbert you know in the
room and Louis in the room but John and
Alec and Steve and a number of our
writers also perform on the shows so you
get exactly what you got in the room I
always go I think the announcer ago we
now return to and then they go see when
you say it makes sense but about return
to you it's like spewpa spewpa what ah
yes no button two people remember your
van der plug know what what do you
personally that's like you like you know
who John is no no I kind of do did that
one gag and I was new Bryan I mean these
are all basically my voice it's a good
voice though isn't it ladies really good
ladies back on the bed and have only
talked to your crotch very handsome boys
right Belgard until Nick right here
ah flerbert stay what's up how's the
source more people's in here ah
I'm just curious what's your favourite
bit like going through now 14 15 years
coming up what like what's the can you
pick one is there one that's like that's
my family guy but we go down Bart Bart
jumping over the gore oh so I have one
it's uh Peter in the guy Stewie Brian
they've all taken epic act to see who's
gonna puke first and it's one of those
jokes that goes on and on and on just
vomit vomit vomit vomit vomit and then I
get to enter Lois I'm confused enters
with a giant pot and says how much
chowder that's I think that's my
favorite age on Viner pitch that bit did
you think yeah I was part of it ah don't
be modest this guy
well yeah but I also feel like we we
don't give enough credits because we
have a great animation staff like one of
my favorite things that I hadn't seen
fully done was when Peter puts holes in
the back of the of the pet frog and then
kills it and the animators do such a
good job of like creating the real
gravity and just the the moments that
like we we think of sometimes but they
actually have to do the hard work of or
they come up with and it's like it's
great to have your someone has your back
comedic Lee because at the end of the
day it's a very visual show and and John
is right because our directors in the
Simpsons family Guy crossover we had a
homer
Peter chicken like fight and we scripted
a number of the things that happen in it
but Peter Shem who's our supervising
director and directed that one turned in
seven and a half minutes of this fight
and you know we probably only cut ten or
fifteen seconds I mean we thought it
would be three or four minutes but he
just you know took a huge swing and
added so much can we talk about that for
me because that was epic like how did
that I mean I've heard you guys talk
about it but for those who didn't like
how did that how hard was that to get to
happen The Simpsons family got this is
the guy who made it all happen well it
I ate where I admitted this importance I
drew those guys and I you worked at the
Simpson and I think did you wait did you
go to Harvard
stop Alek my mother's not listening to
New York state prosecutor I was all
those things it's your best friend
Commissioner of the NBA in any event who
was your brother-in-law back to cartoons
back to cartoons when I spoke to Al Jean
and Mac raining I think they knew that
it was going to be done in the right
spirit as and it's true a lot of writers
on our show were fans of The Simpsons
The Simpsons did you know come first and
do a lot obviously and they let us do it
and you know maybe part of it was the
store we pitched was that you know so
much a family guy had been you know in
homage as Jim Brooks would say to the
Simpsons but they were very game and
their entire cast came to our table read
which was really great
I was very exciting that was a highlight
having them there and doing that
together that table readers and reading
all your words and it's from what I've
heard they were like yep you guys do it
and you guys got to put them in the
world I'm not such that's got it had to
be such a fun yeah they only had all in
Jim Brooks Mac raining and Al Jean had
two small notes for the whole thing and
one of them was we had a bit where Hans
Moleman ran through a farmers market
accidentally killing people and Matt
Groening said I don't want Hans to be a
murderer or anything right that's a
chance fair that was fair ah and one
other small thing that I don't even
remember he said he didn't want Peter
Griffin to be in it now it was in one of
the monologues I'll just say where Peter
Griffin finally takes on The Simpsons
after being dumped on by Homer you know
we took a number of shots that Seth was
so game about about Family Guy and it
there was one line about the demographic
audience of The Simpsons and I remember
saying to those guys if Peter has to
fight back a little you know and your
demo is a little you know older than
ours so we modified that one line I
think other than that nothing very cool
we actually have I think we have a clip
of the the crossover episode so let's uh
throw to a clip shall we this is
exciting because it only aired a year
and a half ago
and run away be the last to see a little
clitoris or Italy okay I got a great
idea how we're gonna find my stolen car
we'll throw a car wash free for stolen
cars and then when we find it we'll
actually charge the guy
well none of these is my car well we
promised these scumbags a show
oh it gets better and that was uh a lot
of the work of Dom Bianchi who's another
one of our supervising directors on the
show who helped Peter with that segment
give a talk into the microphone rich Dom
bianchi deserves credit for that that's
the main that's the headline you turn up
your radio please
uh what was it was it a difficult
process merging the animation of the two
shows or was it actually just like a
scale like how did that were they thus
the right sizes there were you know
things that even people who work in
animation when it anticipated and David
Silverman who is theirs was their
original supervising director came over
and gave seminars for some of our
storyboard artists some of whom had work
Peter Shin had worked at The Simpsons
um the colors had to be buried it's not
exactly the yellow of the Simpsons or
the you know skin color of so combining
the show's was sort of like this that's
that's good it was beautiful yeah it
will continue after the panel so um
obviously uh Cleveland
uh got a spin off if there are any other
characters that you think oh this
character needs more airtime or I would
love to see or it's my dream to explore
this characters universe just a little
bit more who would it be visits anyone
have like a son Herbert and Chris moving
in together New York City loved him
I like it I don't know yeah people
always say uh quagmire you know I always
heard when Cleveland was coming out that
you know people also thought quagmire
should have especially never came up
never never actually wanted to pursue
that I think Cleveland is sort of a
richer deeper character than quagmire he
seems kind of OneNote his four seasons
out of it
you really needed five all right and the
opposite like the Simpsons just killed
off a character is there one character
you would kill off and get rid of
forever
maybe Herbert oh listen hit it
you don't really need to yummy I we have
killed off characters in the past but
you know in the world of animation you
can just sort of ignore them just kind
of never come back to them again and
they sort of die by you know can we talk
about that though for a minute when
Brian was hit by a car and killed the
backlash online the names that I was
called on Twitter equal worth an
animated character it started with C and
ended with T yeah carrot um yeah people
were so upset that Brian was dead and I
believe it was the same day or week but
like Nelson Mandela passed and no one
gave his
I remember that Ryan died it was madness
people lost their minds my favorite
thing there was a report there was a
columnist in the LA Times a legitimate
big newspaper that hated it and doesn't
like Family Guy and came out with a
column when Brian returned and said the
writers responded to fan outrage in a
craven manner by immediately bringing
Brian back and it was it took us 10
months to animate those episodes it's
not like we quickly draw something new
and put it on the air two weeks later I
ears it takes like a year for our each
show to be made now isn't that isn't it
closer to a year it's a little yeah I I
look at it too though in a more positive
way which is I think that you know we
all expected there would be a reaction
we didn't expect that there would be
that magnitude of reaction but we took
it as a sign that people really were had
had over the years gotten so attached to
these characters that there was genuine
upsetness when he when he passed away
and so I think we kind of took it as a
sign of wow people have yes we do you
know a lot of wacky gags in a week in
week out but on some level people really
have come to appreciate things develop
some affection by the character you have
to buy me dinner if you want to call me
a
that's just our and you you know what
you don't also caused other upsetness
was the death threat that Steve received
after
oh I did receive a death threat yeah
that so the night that it aired
I still have it on my phone it's really
terrible and profane but someone called
and it somehow got to my voicemail at
our office and left a really really
heinous death threat saying they wished
I got hit by a truck and that Seth would
die and Wow so people are really good
it's sort of the lesson of this get it
that way yeah we've gotten a little bit
of that reaction when we said ill things
about DC Comics uh yeah fans are
passionate um I want to ask you you guys
uh you know you are humble and modest
people but I have to say Family Guy has
had such an impact on storytelling and
comedy and like there's so many jokes
like like you know when I'm I write
comedy with my friends who will bring up
something like nope that's a Family Guy
joke or they did that on Family Guy can
you talk to us about the impact of your
storytelling style your cutaways and
just how you've seen that grow and how
its influenced comedy it started too
soon frankly I think that's why we got
cancelled because Family Guy came out in
99 right before the internet exploded so
I think the internet coming around was
part of our success and you know you can
sample a five-second cutaway or a you
know 30-second cutaway or watch a whole
act and it's sort of tailor-made for
this time in media so I think that's the
DVDs we're really really the thing that
resuscitated us because I bought them
yeah I bought it I heard I is it true
that they expected to sell a hundred
thousand box sets of the first season or
two and they sold three million I
thought I always heard that yet at that
point the show was just dead it was
fifty episodes that they were gonna put
in the garbage basically but then they
thought I always put this on DVD they
hope they'd sell 100,000 DVDs in the
first year alone they sold three and a
half million or something like that yeah
also I think that you know in terms of
the of impact a show like 30 rock I feel
like borrowed a lot of their format from
Family Guy they do crazy cutaways and
shrubs absolutely I don't know I'm not
sure about that book cut away really
yeah it was family got writers but yeah
so 30 rock I think definitely took our
template and ran with it and I think
ironically the Creator stays dark yeah
the stars of that show sort of poo-poo
Family Guy and it's ironic hey oh yeah
you know I don't even I don't like that
show
I don't either it's all fair it's
totally fair they don't they totally do
the swipe away absolutely well I know
you guys that we got to let you go but
this was such an honor to have you come
and tell us the stories thank you so
much any season 15 it's four it's 15 now
starting this fall thank you so much for
coming thank you thank you thank you
thanks for being here make sure the cast
and writers a Family Guy you guys thank
you for making us laugh awesome thank
thank you bye hey guys uh thank you for
being here and please and please stick
around we have an American Dad panel
coming up at 11:15 you can stay right
here hang out and we're gonna have some
fun thanks again to mafia 3 for
sponsoring this episode
to watch our previous show click the box
to the left and to see everything from
screen junkie central click the box to
the right